yeah you're a closer thank you i've
never heard that before
you are it's what's interesting is that
if i look at your life story and i think
wow you know there have been some major
speed bumps in your
life the triumphs are what you look at
and you can't
that's what makes you a closer work has
kept me accountable
my whole life right i've been a good
girl like with work yes you can't have
had the career that you
have and be as diversified as you are
if you're a complete by the way but it
was on your show
and i drank too much and i have never
forgiven myself
nor will i ever forgive myself really
because
whatever personal thing i do nobody
sees it even though i'm an imperfect
person and i tout that and i've had that
liberty since i was a kid because it was
all out there
yeah and it was either boohoo about it
or
say god it's sort of redeeming to not
have to pretend to be perfect
but i really want to apologize to you
because
i really like uh i just
i will never let that happen again oh
god well so sorry you know
i'm used to people being overserved on
my show
and so i don't even have a totally clear
memory of it
but you don't need to apologize to me
for being over served on my show that
that is that happens oh god you're a
great club of people
you have every kind of person on your
show everyone has come to play from
meryl streep to oprah
and then you have to be the un
ambassador with the greatest skill set
you know in your reunions and
what you have done is my favorite thing
in the world
you have mixed tones
i love you for getting that because i am
all about high and low
and that is my entire goal in everything
that i'm doing